*Musique asiatique traditionnelle*
Ok j'ai pris à droite
Dans une toute petite rue
J'sais pas où ça mène mais ça à l'air cool !
Mais ces gens là viennent de monter et ils redescendent déjà ! Je pense qu'il y a une grosse impasse.
On lance un sondage :
Marquez en commentaire si vous pensez que c'est une impasse ou pas !
*rires*
J'ai gagné c'est totalement une impasse.
Il n'y a rien du touuuuuut... ♪
Et c'est joli comme touuuuuut ♫
*blanc*
Je vous explique la situation, je suis en train de tâter a faire un coup de drone parce que c'est vraiment trop beau ici.
Le 'blème c'est qu'il y a des câbles au dessus de moi...
Et le 'blème c'est qu'il y a la police dans ce pays, aussi.
Bon en vrai, je me suis renseigné si ils viennent, normalement tu payes juste 150€ d'amende.
Euuh... par exemple en Chine tu vas en prison
Bon aller, on va se faire kiffer !
*jolie petite musique*
C'est impossible, il décolle pas droit + y a des câbles plus je peux que reculer et pas avancer.
Premier plan en drône trop cool *rire*
On finit sur un plan de mes pompes.
Ça tue sa mère.
Franchement c'est tellement utile d'avoir un drône.
Les amis, j'ai trouvé l'endroit où on voit tout les toits des maisons traditionnelles, c'est magnifique, regardez.
*voix qui résonne* Ceci est de toute beautéééé...
Franchement j'ai bien une idée, on a pas trop envie de faire un coup de drône là... *rires*
*du coréen*
Touche pas à mon drone bâtard, tu sais pas qui je suis moi.
Ok attention c'est parti !
Le drône se situe dans une zone interdite...
Le décollage est désactivé.
*en chantant* On va y arriver ! ♪ *bruit de buzzer*
Là je suis en train de suivre un petit circuit en fait,
Y a une petite carte
Et du coup on passe par plein de petits rues comme ça.
C'est très très beau , très traditionnel et je vais dire ça encore 600 fois jusqu'à ce que je sois dans une zone où je puisse faire du drone
Voilà, je suis frustré.
Bukchon Traditional Crafts Experience Center
Voilà, si vous voulez vous crafter une coiffe du Bouftou ,
c'est là qu'il faut aller .
Ils font les portes à ma taille !
Ils sont sympa ils ont pensés à moi
Je dépasse le truc !
C'est minuscule mec !
Frodon a pris sa retraite ici mec
Je me suis rendu à l'atelier de craft et y'a pas de coiffe Bouftou
En fait c'est juste une technique qu'ils font en Corée.
Enfait ils appuient avec leur doigts pour mettre de la feuille d'or sur leur tissus.
regardez
Voilà! Bon les amis je viens de sortir de cet endroit.
C'était super beau, y avait plein de trucs fait main qui utilise la technique dont je viens de vous parler.
Et j'ai craqué j'achète un cadre.
ils expliquaient plein de trucs et c'est sacré donc j'avais pas le droit de prendre des photos.
Du coup je deviens un peu parano, j'ai l'impression que tout est sacré.
Genre ça c'est un banc, un simple banc et j'ai demandé si c'était sacré et si pouvais m’asseoir dessus.
C'était le quartier traditionnel
En fait c'est carrément habité il y a plein de pancartes: chut, fermez vos gueules les touristes...
Il y a le wifi hein, pour dire à tes amis que la Corée c'est bien. Et leur demander de venir dans ce pays
Les amis je me trouve actuellement devant un télésiège.
Pourquoi faire? pour rejoindre la Namsan tower. Qui est tout là haut.
On peut la voir, là. Elle dépasse totalement
Pour les gens courageux, y'a un chemin à pied
Tous ces gens sont comme nous, ils n'ont pas de courage
Et pas de muscles accessoirement
*musique asiatique et relax*
C'est de toute beauté
Bah voilà on est tout en haut, absolument génial
Et il y'a une tour là-bas, on peut aller en haut vous pensez ?
Ça par contre j'ai peur d'aller dedans
On est serein, on y va ou pas ?
Vas-y on y va nique
Et voilà la vue en haut de la tour
Voilà heureusement que j'ai le courage de monter en haut de la tour
Parce que putain mec la vue est ouf
EXCELLENT, C'EST FAUX
Je sais, vous me croirez jamais mais j'viens d'aller voir et on peut pas y aller en fait
C'est un restaurant au deuxième truc
Sinon j'avais pas peur hein j'suis courageux
Ok j'ai trouvé la meilleur attraction (euh) de l'endroit
On a réussi à aller dans la tour mais on peut pas monter
Regardez ! Je vais me prendre en photo avec la star de mon choix
Ouiii!!
Ok 'faut se mettre derrière la ligne
On est bien
Eeeeh
Elle est parfaite
Là c'était l'entrainement maintenant on fait la vrai.
Attention ! Résultat des courses
Nul à chier !
Excelleeeent
*Musique hip-hop*
Les amis... Il est temps de prendre notre revanche sur Séoul.
On nous a interdit de faire du drone, et bah pas de soucis
Parce que à Séoul il y'a un parc à drones
Ça fait 27 000 m².
Mon gars, je sors l'artillerie lourde.
*Musique joyeuse et relax*
*Encore la musique traditionnelle asiatique*
Les amis. Jour 2.
Aujourd'hui on va commencer la journée avec un peu de shopping.
J'vous ferai un petit Hall après
Et après ça : Fiesta loca baby pourquoi ?
Parce que j'vais me faire mon deuxième tatouage
En fait, quand j'suis allé en Colombie rejoindre mon frère
Je me suis fait le crabe ici présent
Je me suis dit que dans tous les pays où j'irai, j'aimerai me faire un tatouage.
Du coup, aujourd'hui, je vais me faire mon tatouage coréen
Et je rappellerai un tatouage qui s'appelle : Hugotatoo (si je dis pas de bétise)
Qui a un style un peu (euuh) Kawaii, rigolo
Y'a pas mal de points sur ce tatouage, c'est très très beau je trouve
J'ai hâte de découvrir ça mais avant attention
Shopping, je claque les doigts, et je vous fait un Hall
Oh mon dieu, raccord très très mal fait, bah voilà
Je reviens du shopping et j'ai acheté un petit pull de Hipster
Voilà on dirait mon frère
Et avec ceci un super manteau beige, les filles alors celui là je vous le conseille parce qu'il est beige et que c'est un parfait mixte entre le blanc et le noir.
J'ai aussi acheté des petites boucles d'oreilles noires parce que... *bégaie* ah c'est flou !
Ah ok y en a une qui est tombée zut *rires forcés*
Après ce moment malaisant qu'est ce qu'on va faire ?
On va aller visiter enfin, visiter... J'ai déjà fait quand j'étais déjà venu en mars, mais on va aller à Hongdae .
Euh... Le quartier que je kiff en Corée c'est mon quartier préféré. Allez on attends quoi ?
Les amis bienvenue à Hongdae.
C'est le quartier où il y a le plus de jeunes et le plus de petites boutiques et de petits commerces.
On se croirait un peu au Japon.
Et c'est là ou j'étais venu l'année dernière .
En mars.
Du coup c'est pas l'année dernière.
Arrêtez de rentrer dans les détails !
Y'a plein de gens, plein de petites boutiques un peu hipster ou c'est genre des jeunes designers qu'ont fait les fringues.
Et pas mal de petits restos
'fin c'est vraiment pour moi le meilleur quartier.
Si vous venez en Corée, venez à Hongdae.
*musique K-pop*
Je tape de la main ... sur la table
parce que dans 3h et demie c'est l'heure du tatouage
J'ai trop hâte
parce que je sais moi-même pas à quoi il va ressembler encore.
Je le saurais que quand on sera au salon.
Donc il va faire 10 cm à peu près le tatouage.
Comme ton zizi.
Bah je peux faire des blagues lourdes personnes comprends.
Y'a un problème ?
Et bah non.
Le moment est venu de tester ce qui s'apparente à être des boucles d'oreilles.
Oh mon dieu ça y est !
La deuxième.
J'ai toujours plus galéré pour la droite.
Je pense parce que je suis gaucher.
Par derrière j'y arrive mieux, rien de sexuel.
Le vlog d'un mec qui essaie de mettre des piercings dans l'oreille*rires*
Chaque seconde qui passe est un risque supplémentaire
sur lequel je vais me prendre un pouce rouge.
Oh c'est bon !
Je suis très content parce qu'ils sont tout petits.
Comme vous pouvez constater j'ai des oreilles de nains.
C'est mon défaut.
Mais j'entends bien hein.
Les amis je viens d'arriver au salon de HugoTatoo.
Et c'est très très très très très beau.
Magique.
Le jet-lag est toujours présent.
Heu ... Y'a p'têtre moyen que je m'endorme.
Mais c'est ce que je dit mais en vrai j'aurais tellement mal que je vais bien bien être réveillé.
Il dessine même sur des cailloux.
C'est beaucoup trop drôle.
Il fait des tests.
Ce doux bruit qui m'indique que je vais avoir très mal.
*musique rythmée*
Les amis vous me croirez jamais,
je me suis endormi pendant le tatouage.
Il m'a dit que j'étais le premier client à m'être endormi pendant le tatouage.
*rires*
Je dis ça pour la vanne mais c'est vraiment arrivé.
Très très beau.
Bon, là ça bave, c'est dégeu.
Mais heu ... c'est le temps que ça cicatrise quoi.
Et je vais rentrer faire un énorme dodo.
De retour à la chambre d'hôtel.
Mais qu'elle est belle,
qu'elle est belle cette petite chouette.
Non sans déconner je suis hyper heureux.
Il a fait du super boulot.
En plus, on as pu un peu échanger avec lui sur la Corée.
Voilà, lui qui est un vrai coréen un peu undergroung
Parce que ici, si vous savez pas, être tatoueur c'est illégal.
Et en plus lui il est vraiment tatoué, bah ...
comme vous avez pu le voir sur le visage etc..
Et c'est pas du tout admis en fait ici d'être tatoué.
C'est très mal vu.
Et il disait qu'il s'en battait les couilles du regard des autres.
Les gens qui le voient comme un monstre il s'en fout.
Et même temps mieux comme ça au moins ils m'approchent pas
*rires*
Il baise la vie lui, c'est un ouf !
Puis bah c'est la fin de ce vlog.
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu.
Putain, j'ai plus d'énergie...
Puis je vous dit à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo.
C'était l'outro la plus blasée de la chaîne youtube.
Je parle pas fort on dirait que ma mère dort dans la pièce d'à cotée
Et qu'elle va venir m'engeuler si je parle trop fort.
OOUUUOH JE SUIS UN GANGSTER !